see well I'm not an alcoholic
you know I just well I don't even know
what the alcohol world is like but every
time I go to 7-Eleven guess what it's
not the guy's cutting grass that's
buying them it's the what who is it
homeless peoples
[Music]
Anthony did you know
there is no actual whiskey and bottles
of fire the small ones yeah I do know
that yeah really it's just malt liquor
and whiskey flavor
wait so if it's bigger if it's bigger
it's fine they have the real deal the
smaller these bottles say Fireball
Cinnamon whiskey oh the small ones say
Fireball Cinnamon
oh and then the small ones the ones the
homeless people get so they're not doing
anything illegal technically wow
consumers are suing Sazerac Company
Incorporated the makers of Fireball
whiskey for fraud and misrepresentation
as the as this has been uncovered some
people don't want Malt Liquor you know
they want some well it's kind of like
how it's kind of like how like you know
a truly has malt and not like I guess
actual vodka or whatever and there's
some that have actual vodka but not
those specific Brands they use The Malt
trick so people are arguing that they're
intentionally misled yes exactly wow and
so
um and they're sold everywhere right 170
000 stores so
um people are basically saying this is
like a widespread fraud case
what the label means to say is that the
product contains natural whiskey flavors
and other flavors but by not including
the word flavors after natural whiskey
purchasers look closely will expect the
distilled Spirit of whiskey was added as
a separate ingredient that's true
because other products non-alcoholic
have to say flavoring right so that
they're not following the same
stipulation that goes for like just
cereal
the lawsuit further states that getting
the lack of whiskey 99 Cents for 1.7
fluid ounces is overpriced whoa this
kind of yeah I mean hey they got away
with it for a long time huh probably
[__] [__] for Malt Liquor can't you
get like something like this for two
bucks yeah dude it's funny because when
you're when you're already beyond the
fine amount
cares like you know what I mean like
they've made enough money that all you
got us we'll pay the penalty yeah and
now we'll have to change the wording big
Pharma companies like all the like
settlements that they have and it's a
lot but then they're like we'll just
keep paying it because we make way more
yeah dude we got to mislead our
customers 170 000 stores these are sold
in so that's exactly right that's a lot
of liquor stores
7-Elevens too they'll be fine gas
stations groceries everyone's gonna
forget about this [__] too I never
thought that especially alcoholics
people I also thought that homeless
people were the only ones that bought
the mini I keep saying that
Hunter
lion I've never seen normal people buy
them either I thought who's buying them
the the normal ones uh those are the
small ones and duty free because those
you don't have to uh keep in a bag and
not drink but do you go to a gas station
and get a little baby one no right like
if you're gonna drink with your friends
you buy the big bottle I thought those
were for like the hotel minibars yeah oh
the hotel you can't bring duty-free on
the plane anymore and drink it you can
bring it no the little ones you're
allowed to you can yeah that's why in
airports you're allowed to buy those
yeah they don't put them in the bags
that are sealed that have to stay sealed
see well I'm not an alcoholic
you know I just well I don't even know
what the alcohol world is like but every
time I go to 7-Eleven guess what it's
not the guy's cutting grass that's
buying them it's the what who is it
homeless peoples
yeah his butt crack yup it's either that
or they're buying a big old thing of
malt liquor like this big
more people usually get nope normal
people don't get none of that [__] they
get Budweiser
they get Heineken they get Corona and
then they usually get the six pack or
you see them with wine or like a bigger
bottle what could you guys get the
little ones then homeless
truth imagine We're Cops and we arrested
Joe we could just put them away in like
[__] 30 seconds of testimony
nah I'll never rat on myself
I'm a good eyewitness though because I'm
not gonna PC around who the [__] was
there oh you you mean like they've like
how would you PC around it because
nowadays everyone's so like they don't
even want to give you a description of
the [__] a sailor right or the
[__] accused or whatever they'll just
be like the cop would be like who was
the guy that was robbing the store
um it was uh how do I describe it
I don't want to assume the gender but
they're about like six feet tall and
what were they wearing
um I don't want to judge the their
fashion or their culture but I think
like it was about maybe a pullover
sweater like don't say don't be a silver
sweater yeah it's like what the [__]
don't be descriptive about that I would
just be like that that was a five foot
Asian dude he had a tank top on a tattoo
right in between his [__] eye and he
looked ugly as [__] yeah and I think
he's homeless yeah that's not normal
yeah mini fireball bottles in his hands
apple was homeless as [__] I think lucky
you should probably go back to China
Joe so honestly think he tells you where
they should go
Jail's not good enough for him but when
the cop is sketching it I guarantee you
my description is going to be way more
closer he's like oh can you describe
again
ugly as [__] yeah make him uglier yeah
it's not him give him big ass nose all
right ears um yeah make it like small as
[__] all right that's perfect like no no
more Jewish more Jewish more Jewish in
the eyebrows oh that's a Vietnamese nose
give it a Jew nose Juno's yeah I think
that's gonna be that's what people need
to do because nowadays they're like
they're trying to be so [__] polite
that they're not even polite to the
victim anymore whoever got assaulted
they're like oh [__] it let's just show
all that [__] but then they blur the
face of the person who's like commend
the crime they're like you don't
actually blow them on sometimes so many
stories it's like the the
religiousness of the victim or whatever
they're like immediately forgiving these
[__] who's like maiming them
and killing their families and [__]
they're like oh you know I'm praying for
this person I forgot and I'm like what
the [__] is there no Vengeance in
people's hearts anymore like they get
they get [__] up and they don't press
charges because they're like like the
person's going away because they don't
even know if you it's like you murder
somebody I don't think you can oh I'm
not gonna press start it's not gonna be
a civil suit
it'd be the State against you but um
they do that thing where they go meet
with them and like forgive them and [__]
yeah it's happening I see it more and
more very hyper Christian that's so
Christian very religious uh Norman has a
really good bit on like describing to
the cops like who did what and he says
some [__] like um all right yeah there's
you know this this car hit a person and
it was an Asian driver not that they're
bad at driving and he had a black guy
who's crossing the street very slowly
not that they do that
and it's super long
like that's a great way of putting it
yeah at least he has the balls to label
what he sees
not these other [__] zoom in on the
delivery of that life please Jesus
Christ
what was the last time you had to be a
witness for like a a crime he doesn't
rat on anyone I don't [__] rap bro
but I'll tell you this there was a a
homeless man in front of my store
scaring the [__] out of one of my
employees right she came out just by not
having a deed to a house at his body
what do you mean you're not a homeowner
she was [__] squeegee and those
and this [__] started getting in
in a fight with the air dude yeah
started punching the [__] National
and ah she ran back inside I was like
what's what what the hell happened
because there's a man that's fighting
and I'm like oh [__] who the [__] up
because just the air like he was
punching the air [__] yelling scaring
children and [__] did he have really
small ears and a really big Jewish nose
nah he was a tall guy white man all
right and I know that he's a man because
he looked like one and he had a tank top
on yeah [__] rainbow Crocs on he had
[__] like a Hurley type of board
shorts that went past his kneecaps and
he was about six feet tall all right and
he's been in the Sun so long and you
know when white dudes getting the Sun so
long they turn like lobster red it was
like that and it was a bit rip reptilian
because of his skin was very very dry
very dry even though we're in a humid
place it was dry as [__] all right and
then this will smell like alcohol he was
fighting so when I went out there I was
like what the [__] is going on and
obviously everybody was scared they ran
around they didn't want this guy to be
around so I called the security and I
was like this is what he looks like and
then he goes all right we're gonna have
a security guard come in the what does
he look like
hmm
oh the security guard
describe him too I'm not saying the same
[__] over again
he comes
this [__] security guard was
like Herbert from Family Guy oh like the
old dude oh yeah yeah yeah
dude the pedo dude yeah yeah the old man
this guy looks like if you get like a
leaf and go like this it'll blow him
down he's such a old Hunchback slow
[__] he starts walking his way
over and it's me and him just watching
this homeless dude and I'm looking over
like
this guy's gonna [__] your ass up yeah
and then so we just follow him out until
he leaves the whole premise did he tell
him like Hey you can't be here or no he
just watches them what if he's like Mike
from Better Call Saul though well
Security Guys afterwards I was like why
you know why don't you guys engage and
it's because sometimes you cause more
problems by confronting them so as long
as there's more problems than
confronting so it's like so like it just
let him like burn their [__] out and
then they'll leave in most cases and
then they only intervene when they're
actually posing a threat to somebody
there so I'm like dude but this was
trying to like box the air [__]
leaves whatever it is and I'm like he's
trying to conjure up some spirits and he
came back again so I had to do the same
thing what do you look like that time
yeah the second time he came back he had
the same clothes rainbow Crocs Hurley
kind of board shorts below past his
knees past his knees get a tank top skin
this time was more Brown I think it
calmed down from the time earlier it was
more tan though yeah but this is
different person he wasn't punching the
air what was he doing so there was a
family that was walking by my store and
when he came by he tried to pick a fight
with a dude he was a [__]
[__] like something like that
with like the dad or something yeah yeah
and then uh the funniest thing is so it
was he's white right and then the guy
that's with the family he's also white
so he passed by him and he goes I'm a
local I've been here for six months and
that's what he told the guy what is it
how long do you think you have to be to
be alone I don't know maybe six months
but maybe that's when you felt entitled
like he's a local he was telling I'm a
[__] local get the [__] out of here
what did the dad do they were just
shocked because they're like what the
[__] yeah what was the dad wearing
I don't know he wasn't the Vic he was
the victim so I'm gonna protect the
victim's identity would you say he's a
Survivor and what does it mean to be a
survive
he got yelled at so I I not told him hey
don't worry this guy just crazy and then
I was like I was just standing there
watching him while I was on the phone
he's back he's back tell him to go
was this a Monterey Park
Hawaii did this did this article go
where you were hoping it would yeah it
did
to script everyone did their lines too I
don't know
[Music]